delighted to have you all here at this
forum where we hope we'll be able to
provide you with some useful background
it will help you be intelligent citizens
come the election in just four weeks is
the first of two panel discussions that
have been organized by the Economics
Department by Ben [ __ ] the chair of
economics in particular who's done a
terrific job in attracting extraordinary
people to to talk to this community
about very important issues in front of
us and so Ben thanks for that for that
work the three panelists that we have
with us tonight are all have two things
in common they all have a connection to
Yale and they all have done at least
some time in Washington I think a third
thing is they're all leaders in their
fields that relate to important issues
of economics and public policy our first
speaker is going to be out an hour back
was sitting on the far right I guess and
this group because his normal position
but I
but Alan is a graduate of yale college
class of 1973 he's had a very
distinguished career in the field of
public finance at Harvard the University
of Pennsylvania and for many years now
at the University of California Berkeley
Allen is perhaps the preeminent
economist who's worked for firstly his
whole career in the study of Taxation
mainly in the United States but with
some substantial knowledge of tax
regimes elsewhere as well Michael gratz
the next panelist is currently a
professor of law at Columbia University
but only since 2009 he spent the
previous 26 years here on the faculty
right here at the yale law school and
and michael is in a way the legal
counterpart to alan in that he is
perhaps the preeminent lawyer in the
contract law professor in the country
who specializes in the study of taxation
so have an interesting colloquy between
experts on the question of taxes in both
from an economic and a legal perspective
but they both have a little bit of a
little bit of knowledge which as you
know is a dangerous thing of each
other's fields Amanda Kowalski is an
assistant professor here in the
Economics Department and she is a rising
star in the study of the economics of
healthcare and she that i mentioned that
all three have had some government
experience alan served for a time on the
as deputy chief of staff of the joint
committee on taxation of the Congress
michael has had a couple of stints at
the Treasury Department a one the most
recent one and he was assistant to the
secretary and special counsel to the
secretary of the Treasury and Amanda
between her years of undergraduate study
and and her graduate study spent a year
on the staff at the Council of Economic
Advisors in Washington so we have people
that are very proficient in their areas
and also with a little bit of practical
dose of practical reality from
experience in government I could say
that the theme tonight is going to be on
one of this of the issues that is at the
center of the election debates and that
has to do with in us what we economists
would call the economics of public
finance but but what but which which you
might think of as policies relating to
taxation government expenditure and in
particular some of the critical areas of
government expenditure health care in
particular which is at the center of the
discussion I mean just to frame this you
know that one of the big issues today is
the question of a very large fiscal
deficit in the United States um partly
structural partly a consequence of the
great recession began in 2008 and the
major issue before us is what
combination of expenditure cuts and tax
increases ought to be employed in order
to close the gap but I think I expect
both Alan and a our back in Michael
breath will address that problem more or
less hat on but of course when you think
about what the major components are of
government expenditure health care and
entitlement programs like Social
Security along with defense spending
loom largest since they consume the
largest share of the expenditures from
the federal budget so hence some
discussion some of the discussion will
focus on a public policy towards health
care and what should be done that in
that sector so we hope this will be
illuminating in the subsequent debate
which is November first I think we will
we will be looking more directly at the
sort of larger macroeconomic levers and
what you know what's what's what can we
do to stimulate employment and output
growth both in short and long run and
that that'll be that is also a subject
of much debate between the candidates
and we'll try to eliminate that as well
there's a huge overlap between these
subjects actually but and I think some
of that will come out tonight so the
format will be each of the three
speakers will make an opening
presentation um then I'll try to
stimulate some discussion among the
panelists and then open up for questions
from the floor and we have about two
hours of for the entire of the entire
discussion I hope you enjoy it i'll call
first then I'll an hour back thank you
very much Rick it's a great pleasure to
be back on campus I let me start with
some recent history a lot of what this
presidential campaign as well as many
others are about our facts and different
people's interpretation of them so i'm
going to ferment much of my talk focus
on what the facts are and how I
interpret them implicit if not explicit
in my discussion will be what I think we
should do about it and I probably more
explicitly ideas will come out in our
following discussion this is a graph of
federal revenues for the last decade
plus and federal expenditures going back
to fiscal year 2001 fiscal year two
thousand is natural year to pick because
it was a previous change in
administration's it was also a high
water mark for the United States in
recent memory of our fiscal situation in
terms of the budget surpluses that we
were running at the time where you see
federal revenues exceeding the federal
outlays federal expenditures during that
fiscal year for the last time so and
we've been in running deficits since
then and of course you can see a big
jump around the most recent change in
administration's between president obama
and president george w bush and with
both large growth and outlays and
reduction in revenues and certainly one
of the criticisms of President Obama
that's come out during the campaign is
that government has been out of control
and has grown very rapidly and as is
usually the case with economic
statistics there's the situations more
complicated than that first thing I'm
going to do in talking about these
statistics is change the denominator
this is we often state these things as a
share of GDP that can be particularly
misleading when you have a very sharp
recession as we've had starting in two
thousand seven because GDP goes down and
everything looks big in the short run
relative to that so let's change that a
little bit and make it relative to
potential GDP more of a trend measure of
the size of the economy and you can see
that pushes down both revenues and
expenditures in recent years but it
doesn't really change the difference
between the very much and it doesn't
change the conclusion that expenditures
have grown and revenues have fallen
under President Obama and if you're
trying to think about what these causes
might be and not simply going back for
years but perhaps going back 12 years
one thing that will naturally come to
mind is the growth in defense two wars
starting earlier in the 2000s which
continued to this day and otherwise a
military buildup more during the
administration of President Bush and
President Obama but one might want to
know how much of that is the story in
terms of what's been going on and and
i'll get to that just just this is the
deficit that comes as a result of the
revenues and expenditures getting back
to the question of defense you can see
that taking defense out and so what i
did here was I took two fiscal year two
thousand one which was the transition
year between President Clinton and
President Bush and I said suppose that
defense as a share of GDP or potential
GDP didn't grow from then because that
was the lowest it got in recent years it
had been trending downward starting with
the fall of the Soviet Union and
continuing downward as the economy grew
very strongly under pres
Clinton and it's been growing ever since
and so suppose you magically had had a
counterfactual experience where defense
spending simply stated the same share of
potential GDP there forever after what
would that have done to government
spending into the deficit and there you
can see and that certainly explains part
of why we've had bigger deficits in
recent years and while we had deficits
under the Bush administration but that's
clearly not the whole story what is
going on here is a common it certainly
if one does one goes back to the bush
administration versus the Clinton
administration it's clear that what was
going on was a recession we had really
it what we had in 2001 as well as the
tax cuts that were passed under
President Bush which produced the
deficits that we had early in the 2000s
more recently leading the defense growth
aside we've had two things that caused
expenditures and revenues to diverge one
is the automatic effects of a weak
economy things that happen automatically
incomes go down so income tax revenues
go down people be kind of unemployed so
unemployment benefits go up and those
things happen automatically those are
what we call what about xterra lies was
in the business and in read in addition
to that we had active fiscal policy we
had beginning in the bush administration
and much more strongly in the Obama
administration we had various
legislation to cut taxes and increase
spending to try to keep the economy from
getting even worse than it than it did
and these two factors the automatic
response and discretionary response
together led to this divergence between
revenues and outlays and that's where we
are and that we have these deficits
which have been quite large relative to
GDP or potential GDP really you would
have to go back to World War two to get
the numbers of similar magnitude and of
course that was a very atypical time as
a result we've had a sharp growth in
national debt as a share of potential
GDP which is just the accumulation of
prior deficits
and it was rising slowly during the Bush
administration but it really took off
with the recession and this again is
something that the Obama administration
has been criticized for its not really a
separate phenomenon from what I've just
been discussing to look a little bit
more closely on the issue of growing
government one might want to look though
at national income accounts and the
various components of what happens in
the economy and this table shows the
growth in real terms scent of to the
current date from two different dates
the first starting date the end of 2007
was when the recession began so that's
the previous high water mark for the
economy the second the second quarter of
two thousand nine which was both early
just at the beginning of the Obama
administration and it's also when the
recession hit its trough that is the
economy has been growing since then and
so these are two useful benchmark dates
to compare where the aconnick to which
to compare where the economy is now and
you can see GDP has grown since it's now
higher than it was when the expansion
peaked at the end of two thousand seven
although not by much and it's of course
much higher than it was at the at the
trough of the recession when we hit
bottom but one of the particularly
interesting things to look at is what's
happened to government because I just
showed you that government has been
growing and buy some views out of
control governments actually been
falling so government is a hole in the
United States as a share of the economy
during the Obama administration has
declined and it's declined at the
national defense spending it's declined
at the state local level very sharply
it's grown it government's spending
other than national defense but not as
quickly as the economy has grown indeed
if you want to look for government
growth you need to look earlier to the
period at the end of the Bush
administration when you see the National
Defense grew more rapidly non-defense
federal spending grew more rapidly at
the end of the Bush administration it
has since then and state local
government although it was falling
actually has fallen since and that's an
unusual pattern because what that's
saying is that as the economy has
recovered government has continued to
contract and this has been pointed out
as a problem in the current recovery you
can look at that in terms of
unemployment growth too and this goes
back to februari 2010 which was when the
unemployed employment stopped flowing
and started rising in the US and it's
typical for employment to start rising
after the economy itself starts growing
and again employment as a whole is gone
up by about 4.2 million jobs since its
low point but not due to anything that's
been happening in the government in fact
government employment has been falling
it's been falling at the federal level
it's been falling at the state and local
level and we've lost about half a
million jobs in government since the
employment hit its low point so it's
continued to work against the general
economic recovery and you might ask how
can it be that government is contracting
at the federal level in terms of what
the government does and employment and
yet we have this big increase in federal
spending well there's a lot of what
federal the federal government does in
terms of spending that doesn't show up
in what we call government and our
national accounts so payment of
unemployment insurance payment of
Medicare payment of Social Security
benefits aid to the States these are all
the kinds of things that have been going
up a lot in recent years they aren't
included in what we look at in the
national accounts so there's no
inconsistency it's just that one needs
to look behind the aggregate statistics
to get an idea of what's going on and
it's hard to and if the idea that
government has been growing that payroll
government payrolls have been increasing
a lot of new government workers have
been hired that that is inconsistent
both with what we see when we look
around especially at the state and local
level but also at the federal level and
it's also in constant and consistent
with the reported statistics so now let
me come to a I've looked at the last 10
years last 12 years
now look at where we are right now
you've probably heard about the fiscal
cliff you you may not be assure exactly
what it is permit me a literary allusion
here the the this may be this may date
me but the this is when i think of the
fiscal cliff this is the kind of thing I
think about the it certainly seems to be
a bad thing and you might ask before
asking what is what what components make
up the fiscal cliff why we got ourselves
in a situation where we're confronting
it and it has nothing to do with
economics it has to do with politics and
I suppose you may need a third panel to
cover that question but it's clear that
there's they're serious problems in the
way our federal government operates what
the fiscal cliff consists of is a bunch
of provisions which change things at the
end of the year some tax cuts that are
some tax provisions that are of
long-standing the bush tax cuts adopted
in 2001 2003 are scheduled to expire
they've already been renewed a couple of
times but if not renewed they will
expire at the end of December there's a
new tax provision adopted as part of the
Affordable Health Care Act which expands
Medicare taxes to income other than wage
and salary income that takes effect then
there were measures undertaken within
the last couple of years as attempts of
further stimulus most importantly a
reduction in payroll taxes which will
expire there's a set of automatic
spending cuts that are in law to occur
by the end of 2012 as a result of a
budget agreement between president obama
and congress when they agreed finally to
raise the debt ceiling which allows the
government to borrow in the summer of
2011 which said we're going to cut
spending and we're going to do it
actively we're going to we're going to
have a committee that's going to make a
decision what spending to cut but if
this committee fails as of course it did
we're going to have automatic spending
cuts and they have to happen by the end
of 2012 and the administration is laid
out what these cuts would be and they
will occur unless there is some
legislation to keep them from happening
and by the way not officially part of
the fiscal cliff but they are in lurking
in the background is the fact that the
debt limit agreement in 2011 will have
to be revisited sometime at the
beginning of 2013 because we're going to
hit the debt ceiling that was raised
then so that just adds to the fun now
what would happen if the fiscal cliff
just stays there and like wile e coyote
we find ourselves at the mercy of
gravity this is what federal budget
deficits would look like according to
congressional budget office projections
between now for the next ten years very
very sharp decline in budget deficits
some Vadhu to the improving economy
because were more tax revenues would be
coming in less fewer unemployment people
would be receiving unemployment benefits
and so forth but a lot of it would be
coming as a result of these all these
explorations the congressional budget
office estimates that the fiscal cliff
would account for essentially a tax
increase in spending cut combined of
about five percent of GDP in the next
year and that's a very very big cut in
the deficit to occur in a year and has
very serious macroeconomic implications
I won't go into them here except to say
that CBO is suggested that would push us
back into another recession if that
actually occurs now if we go over the
fiscal cliff that's the projections if
you take more realistic view and assume
that some of the provisions that are
expelled to expire do because they sort
of been expected to and others that
Congress has been extending will
continue to be extended that it looks
more like that so deficits go down but
that's primarily because the economy is
getting better and then you see
something interesting happening which is
they start going up again and this is
under current policy and so this leads
me to my next
issue which is what's going on if we
look a little bit further out and what's
going on is that there are some things
driving already present in our
government system of expenditures and
revenues but that had become not going
to become continue continually more
important over time which is spending on
old age entitlement programs and this is
sort of thing being talked about but
generally in a fairly unfocused way
here's a way of giving yourself a little
bit more of a sense of why this is an
important issue this is the share of the
federal government's spending other than
interests going to two groups of
spending areas that account together
account for about 85 or 90 percent of
all government spending so these are the
basically the two areas where government
spends the federal government spends
money the Green Line is what we call
discretionary spending it's what in the
old days we thought of is what
government did all spending on non
defense and non-defense things the
non-defense things are schools roads the
post office and things like that
whatever people do in Washington the the
red line is three programs Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid and you
can see if you go back to the early 70s
that the so these three entitlement
programs were very small relative to
spending on discretionary spending and
sometime in the early 90s they crossed
and then you can see that the
projections for the next ten years ease
again from the Congressional Budget
Office are for this trend to continue
and unfortunately it's going to continue
in a way that at least the projections
are it's not so much that defense we're
going to have big deal able to have big
cuts in defense spending and to spend
non-defense spending that will make room
for the spending on these other programs
rather that these other programs are
slated to grow under our current rules
thought that we're going to becoming
more generous but we just have
medical costs going up and a lot more
elderly people in the population and
this is going to be getting more and
more expensive how much more expensive
well here are two projections that I've
done with a co-author recently based on
best available projections for different
programs and then a good deal of
judgment about what policies will be
followed how fast things will grow and
we have two sets of projections
optimistic and pessimistic and you can
think of these is you might want to
label them wildly optimistic and
pessimistic I wouldn't say wildly
pessimistic unfortunately and this shows
what will happen to the national debt as
a share of GDP over the next several
decades and of course one needs to take
these with a grain of salt as you as you
go out into the projection period at
least gives you an idea of where things
are heading on average given projections
and the dashed line there toward the
bottom of the figure is the highest debt
to GDP ratio of the United States is
experienced and it was experienced in
1946 which was the end of a period it's
a period of several years during which
the federal government did a massive
amount of borrowing to pay for World War
two and it fell very sharply after that
is the economy strengthened the
peacetime economy strengthened and
government spending went down in the
post-war period so we're going to cross
that line at some point in the not too
distant future in the next couple of
decades and then it's just going to keep
growing even under the most optimistic
assumptions which as I say are quite
unrealistic and that's why we have in
the long run a very serious problem to
deal with and of course because it's
such a serious problem waiting until the
long run that is waiting decades to deal
with it will make the changes that have
to occur be really to cook draconian so
this brings me to the shortest part of
my talk which is the substance of the
candidates proposals
the President Obama I think it would be
fair to say his proposals are mostly
what his proposals have been that is he
since he was a candidate and made
proposals and as president submitted a
budget each year which had a variety of
tax and spending proposals he has put
forward a program and that is his
program now that is he has not come up
with a bunch of new initiatives as part
of the campaign this year so this list
and this is really just a selective list
of proposals our proposals that have
been his proposals for the last few
years and we're probably familiar with
with most of them repealing the Bush tax
cuts for people with incomes over 250
thousand dollars limit itemized
deductions for the same group of people
raise taxes on multinational
corporations what is the American Jobs
Act that is a stimulus bill that he
proposed last summer this summer of 2011
not surprisingly it went nowhere
remember this was the period during
which the president was at loggerheads
with Congress over raising the debt
limit so saying by the way I know you
won't let the government borrow but how
about enacting this additional stimulus
measure needless to say it didn't it
didn't really happen but it is still I
think officially part of the president's
plan and he's also proposed reducing the
corporate tax rate although in a fuzzy
sort of way that is not fully explaining
how the revenue would be made up from
the loss from reducing the corporate tax
rate now Governor Romney has a more
detailed set of proposals perhaps
naturally because he's a he's a new
candidate he had doesn't have a track
record of being president and so he's
putting forward what he would do if he
were president and i divided them here
into things that take effect primarily
in the short run and in the longer term
and I think it's fair to say these are
generally more controversial proposals
they are one might say bolder and I one
can take that either in a negative or a
positive sense he's proposed read and
you
these will may also be very familiar
given the debate and arguments in the
campaign reducing individual tax rates
by one-fifth offset by unspecified
deductions reductions in tax benefits
this of course was a big issue in the
debate last week and it's been a big
issue the Obama campaign and many other
people saying it's hard to hit all the
targets that Governor Romney says he's
going to hit with these tax cuts in
terms of who will have to bear the
burden of the base broadening that comes
with the tax cuts and whether enough
revenue can be raised that way to pay
for the tax cuts he says he will repeal
the Affordable Care Act which is known
as Obamacare too many two summits known
as Romneycare although not to the Romney
campaign the he has also said however
that he would not repeal all of the
provisions of the Affordable Care Act
and it's a little hard to know what that
means given that some of the provisions
don't work if other provisions are let
go and that really hasn't been explained
he would reduce non-defense government
spending substantially how do I see why
do I say that because he said he would
bring government spending as a share of
GDP down to twenty percent which is
several percentage points lower than I
showed you we've been experiencing
recently and he's also said he would not
cut defense spending and he said he
wouldn't cut a bunch of other things and
what you're left with is a relatively
small part of the budget that would have
to be cut nearly in half in order to
meet his overall target he has proposed
reducing corporate tax rate like
President Obama but he's proposed other
reductions for corporations as well so
more tax reductions there I think
perhaps most significant and it's gotten
some attention but perhaps not as much
as it should have he's proposed a fairly
concrete longer-term measures for both
Medicare and Social Security Social
Security modifying Social Security
benefits in a couple of ways by Ritu
increasing the retirement age and
cutting the way to rate at which
benefits grow that would would
help Social Security stay on the sound
financial footing and perhaps higher
profile proposal is the one originally
associated with his running mate Paul
Ryan to convert Medicare into some sort
of a voucher system where what people
get from the government is capped and
then they more or less or responsible
for additional costs now these are the
proposals you might ask well how do
these relate to the fiscal cliff for
example how do they relate to the
current state of the economy and the
answer is they really don't so in some
ways the campaign is taking place as if
in a parallel world where the current
state of the economy and recent
experience is not really feeding
directly into what the proposals say of
course in some ways they are we you
couldn't repeal the Affordable Care Act
if it if it didn't exist but in other
respects those individual tax cuts cuts
in the corporate rate changes in
itemized deductions none of these things
really have anything to do with the
current state of the economy or recent
experience they are proposals that could
have been made five years ago 10 years
ago or fought 10 or 5 or 10 years from
now and in that sense they more or less
represent to a certain extent campaign
rhetoric than really getting into what
the where the economy is right now and
what it needs well I've mentioned the
both the tax system and the issues both
with the Affordable Care Act and with
Medicare and I'm sure that the next two
panelists will have something to say
about each of those things so at this
point I'd be happy to turn it over to
them thank
I'm Allen did not mention that Romney
was going to turn the Medicaid program
over to the States which is a way to
save a lot of federal money but I'm sure
amanda is going to talk about that so
Allen was given the task of just giving
you the facts in the traditional
economist fashion he used PowerPoint to
do it I have no use for powerpoint and
and I'm going to give you a mix of facts
and opinion unlike Allen so let me start
with a couple of facts the first is we
are in the midst of a presidential
campaign with two candidates who have
very different views about how our tax
system should be revised the second is
that next year is the hundredth
anniversary of the income tax the third
is there are only two views about tax
reform those who think it should happen
something big should happen and it will
and those who think something big should
happen but it won't everybody agrees
that our current system is broken that
it's overly complex that it causes too
many unwise distortions and people's
decisions and that it could maybe made
far more conducive to economic growth
last year was the 25th anniversary of
the Tax Reform Act of 1986 which was the
last major US tax reform and legislation
that many including the bowles-simpson
Commission and Mitt Romney to name just
to want to use as a template for tax
reform now that legislation was surely
the crowning achievement domestically of
Ronald Reagan's presidency and it was
widely heralded as the most important
tax legislation since the income tax was
extended to the masses to help finance
world war two
pundits and politicians from across the
political spectrum are now calling for a
replay I was on a panel a week or so ago
with Andy Stern who was head of the SEIU
and on the bowles-simpson Commission and
he says that everyone is in favor of the
bowles-simpson proposals until they
learn what's in them let me go back to
the 86 tax reform it increased the
permissible amount of tax free income it
lowered and flattened income tax rates
it shut down mass-marketed tax shelters
for high-income individuals it curtailed
the ability of families to shift income
to lower bracket taxpayers and it tax
capital gains at the same rate as
ordinary income by shutting down tax
shelters for individuals and by
repealing tax benefits for equipment and
real estate Congress not only financed
the reduction in the corporate rate from
46 to thirty-four percent but also paid
for a good chunk of individual tax rate
reductions the corporate changes made
the income tax much more neutral across
industries and soon thereafter the 86
axe-bass broadening and rate reducing
measures were adopted by virtually every
OECD nation but the changes that were
wrought by the 86 act have proved
neither revolutionary nor stable
thousands of pages of legislation in the
years since 1986 have narrowed the
income tax base and the rates have crept
upward even though deficits were
becoming a concern by the mid-1980s the
political linchpin of the 1986 act was
revenue neutrality by insisting on
revenue neutrality the Reagan
administration and congressional
leadership were able to in
syst that amendments to the tax bill
could be offered only if they were
offset by revenue gains somewhere else
legislators behaved quite differently in
a context where when to pay Peter they
had to explain just how they intended to
rob Paul tax reform was also
distribution alee neutral so tax reform
was not an occasion in 1986 for shifting
the tax burden down the income scale or
up the income scale distribution new
distributional neutrality along with
revenue neutrality became the linchpins
for tax reform but conditions are very
different today first as allen's talk
demonstrates it's not at all clear that
either revenue neutrality or
distributional neutrality will be enough
given the size of the national debt
projected deficits increases in that
debt in the near and long-term it may
now be essential for tax reform to
produce additional revenues revenue
increasing tax reform will be even more
difficult politically second given the
rise in inequality especially the
increase in the share of income and
wealth concentrated at the very top many
of our political leaders are not willing
to settle for distribution alene neutral
tax reform they and you can count
President Obama among them want to root
use tax reform as an occasion to make
the federal tax system more progressive
not every politician agrees with that
idea a third and i think most
importantly there is no pot of gold from
which to finance tax reform in 1986 as I
said repeal of tax benefits for
investments in plant and equipment along
with shutting down tax shelters and
elimination of the lower rates on
capital gains finance much of the rate
reduction for end of
viduals today given the
internationalization of economic
activity during the past 25 years and
the increased economic competition from
abroad the 1986 acts reliance on
increased taxes of corporate income is
not possible corporations and other
owners of large amounts of capital move
money quickly and easily around the
world making it much more difficult for
any nation including the united states
to tax their income we need to attract
capital to create better conditions for
American workers and businesses and in
order to do that the United States must
be an attractive place for both foreign
and domestic investments and American
companies need to be positioned to take
full advantage of the global economy
technological advances allow vast sums
of capital and the ownership a valuable
intellectual property to be moved around
the world with a click of a mouse and
financial innovations facilitate tax
planning opportunities the
interdependence of the world economy
along with these technological changes
makes trying to impose high income tax
rates on multinational corporations
counterproductive deductions simply
flock to high tax countries and income
flocks to low-tax countries there is
only so much that the United States can
do unilaterally to address this problem
and multilateral cooperation is very
limited I have come to believe that
absent broad international agreement and
cooperation foregoing tax competition
among nations to attract capital a
transformation that is not on the
horizon that al of statutory corporate
tax rate is essential for the US economy
this year our statutory rate is the
highest
in the industrial world so if the
substantive difficulties of designing
sound corporate income tax policies for
today's global economy were not enough
taking political considerations into
account makes the task positively
Herculean corporate income taxes are
very popular with the public despite the
virtually unanimous view among tax
policy analysts that the corporate tax
is a bad tax economically it is child's
play to characterize large corporations
especially large multinational
corporations as villains this is
probably why the public seems to like
attacks that economist tend to hate but
high tax rates on corporate income in
today's global economy are a bad way to
achieve economic growth or to obtain and
maintain progressivity in the tax system
so the corporate tax today should not
and I'm sure will not be able to be used
to finance individual income tax cuts
the way it was in nineteen eighty six at
the most corporate tax reform will have
to be revenue neutral nor can tax reform
be financed through more borrowing that
was George Bush's trick in 2001 and it
cannot be repeated today Alan has showed
us why but I do want to remind you that
in 2001 Alan Greenspan when he was
chairman of the Federal Reserve famously
told the US Senate that the projected
budget deficits were so large that the
government would soon pay off all of its
debt and that the government would have
to begin investing in corporate stocks a
prospect that he abhorred so the good
news is that that problem has now been
solved
our national debt as Alan said is now
larger as a share of our economy that
any time since World War two and then
the debt was owed to Americans today
half is owed to foreigners this time
there is no pot of gold to finance tax
reform unless it is hiding somewhere
under a rainbow people talk about
broadening the tax base and lowering tax
rates but they are reluctant to tell you
what they mean by base broadening so I'm
here to give you the rather ugly truth
the 1986 legislation did not induce
Congress to forsake using the income tax
as a blunt instrument of social and
economic policies politicians from both
parties continued to act as if an income
tax credit or deduction was the solution
to every economic and social ill so that
the internal revenue service today is
not just a tax collector but is also the
administrator of most of our nation's
important spending programs in this
Congress alone there have been more than
700 tax bills introduced most of them
and by most of them I mean all but about
ten proposed new tracks breaks including
probably most famously exempting from
income tax the prizes and cash received
by our Olympic athletes to keep track of
all these tax benefits the federal
budget contains a list of tax
expenditures the number of these tax
expenditure has grown from 128 to 202
since 1986 and once enacted even if
they're ineffective and distortive they
tend to stay in place the total cost in
revenues is about 1.1 trillion dollars
this year but here's the rub
these are not just special interest
loopholes the biggest items are tax
breaks that are widely available to
broad segments of the general public the
largest tax expenditures are very
popular tax advantages for employees
payments for employers payments of their
employees health insurance and pension
savings savings for home mortgage
interest state and local taxes
charitable contributions low rates on
capital gains the Earned Income Tax
Credit state income tax deductions and
these account the ones I just mentioned
for about seventy percent of the total
tax expenditures so no politician wants
to tell you this but if income taxes and
rate reduction and tax reform are to be
financed by broadening the income tax
base these are the tax breaks that will
have to be eliminated or sharply
curtailed both Mitt Romney and Barack
Obama have made some suggestions for
limiting these tax breaks I happy to
talk about their proposals during the
discussion they're quite different and
Mitt Romney's in particular have changed
a bit from the day before the debate
until the debate but but but i'll save
that because that surely would be
opinion the basic point is that there is
a limit to how much curtailing these
deductions can and should finance and so
my view is that the 1986 act is a
promise failed and i do not believe that
the best path for tax reform is simply
to try and repeat the income tax reform
of the past 25 years
today's tax reform challenges as Alan
has indicated and as I have suggested
are daunting we need to reduce deficits
and debt and the long run we need to
promote economic growth and in the
international economy the United States
can no longer i think afford to rely so
heavily on income taxation to finance
our federal expenditures what we need is
a completely new tax system we are a low
tax country when you look across the
world but are we are not a low income
tax country our income tax takes the
same share of economic output as does
the income tax of most osed nations and
reforming the income tax alone will do
nothing to change this fundamental
disadvantage and so we need to
restructure our tax system there are
many proposals Allen himself has one for
consumption taxes taxes on consumption
we need a new national tax on sales of
goods and services there are lots of
proposals out there I will choose to
tell you mine that's no accident it is
quite practical to combine a tax on
sales and goods and serve of sales and
goods and services with an income tax on
higher income people that raises at
least as much revenue as the existing
law the Tax Policy Center the
nonpartisan tax policy center has
estimated my plan and here's what they
say that if you enacted a twelve point
three percent value added tax or tax on
goods and services that would fund
$100,000 exemption from the income tax
and remove a hundred and fifty million
Americans from the income tax rolls in
order to make this system revenue
neutral with the district with a
distribution of the tax burden similar
to that of current law you would need an
income tax rate of 16
sat on incomes between 100 and 200
thousand dollars and twenty-five and a
half percent on incomes over two hundred
thousand dollars you could have a
15-percent corporate tax rate and you
could have payroll tax offsets and debit
cards in order to protect low and
moderate income people from a tax
increase small businesses with up to
five hundred thousand dollars or even a
million dollars could be exempt from the
goods and services tax if the IRS were
to gear up for such a tax the estimates
are it would take 18 months to two years
after Congress and acts the law and
experience with implementing such taxes
elsewhere suggests that during the
interval people would buy large amounts
of durable goods and other things in
order to avoid the tax needless to say
in the short term that would stimulate
consumption which is what as I
understand it is one of the things we'd
like to do over the longer term we'd
have lower taxes on savings and
investments the vast majority of
Americans would never have to deal with
the IRS the US would be a much more
favorable place for corporate
investments and the tax fits well with
international trade agreements it would
solve many of the problems of
international tax planning that we now
face and we could tax imports and exempt
exports consistent with our trade
agreements and at least over the near
term that would produce a lot of revenue
for the federal government in terms of
the trade imbalance that we that we now
have it would return the income tax to
its pre World War two status as a
relatively small tax on a thin slice of
high-income individuals so this time in
my view what we need is a major overhaul
of our nation's tax system and not just
another oil change and lubrication thank
you
thank you so i'll be speaking about what
we have learned from the massachusetts
health reform and what that implies for
the likely impact of the Affordable Care
Act if it's implemented as under current
law so i should say first i'll give you
an overview of what's in the Affordable
Care Act and also what was in the
Massachusetts health reform I'll show
you the impact that Massachusetts health
reform had on coverage and then I'll
summarize findings from three papers
that I've worked on the relate to
Massachusetts health reform and that
have implications for national reform so
first I'll talk about the impact on
hospitals on coverage and preventive
care second I'll talk about the impact
on the labor market and third I'll talk
about the impact on the individual
health insurance market in adverse
selection in that market I'm also
prepared to answer more general
questions in the Q&A but I'm keeping
this closer to to my own research on
Massachusetts health reform so just to
motivate for you why it's interesting to
examine what happened in the
Massachusetts health reform and in 2006
I have a quote from the first
presidential debate by President Obama
it says the fact of the matter is we use
the same advisers and they say it's the
same plan so that's a political
statement i'll let you to judge I'll
leave you to judge that for yourself but
I'll show you what actually was in the
Massachusetts health reform which was
passed under Governor Romney then
Governor Romney into 2006 and then also
show you the similarities to national
health reform so Massachusetts health
reform was mainly aimed at expanding
health insurance coverage and it did
this through five main approaches so
first it had an individual mandate that
individuals must have health insurance
coverage or pay a penalty second there's
a mandate that employers must offer
coverage or pay a penalty third there
are expansions in the traditional
Medicaid program which made health
insurance available to more indigent
people and then also a new system of
subsidies was established for people who
were still low income but to high income
to qualify for Medicaid and then lastly
the state of Massachusetts set up an
insurance exchange called the connector
which connected people who were wanted
to purchase insurance with the health
insurers that sold that insurance as you
can see on the right side of the figure
the Affordable Care Act has the same
three has the same five main elements
aimed at expanding health insurance
coverage the individual mandate the
employer mandate the Medicaid expansions
the subsidies and also state-based
insurance exchanges you can also see on
the slide that the penalties associated
with the mandates are slightly different
under under the national reform than
they were under the Massachusetts reform
and you can also see that the subsidies
are different the in particular the
subsidies for health insurance coverage
extend up to four hundred percent of the
poverty line under the national reform
which you should think about is about
eighty thousand dollars a year income
for a family of three but only up to
three hundred percent of the federal
poverty line under the Massachusetts
health reform another big difference
between the two reforms which came up in
the debate is that Massachusetts health
reform was mainly just aimed at
expanding health insurance coverage and
even though the national health reform
was also aimed at expanding health
insurance coverage there were also cost
control measures in the national health
reform so now I just like to show you
that the nasa chooses health reform did
increase health insurance coverage so in
this chart which is based on the cps the
current population survey you can see
health insurance coverage outside of
massachusetts over time in the bottom
solid red line in the graph and then in
the top dashed blue line you can see
coverage in massachusetts so one thing
that will strike you from this graph is
that massachusetts started with a much
higher level of coverage than other
states did but the coverage rates were
growing at roughly the same they had
basically the same trends as in other
states there are two red lines they're
the two vertical red lines show the
implementation period for massachusetts
health reform and you see that coverage
did increase dramatically in
massachusetts following reform relative
to other states another thing to point
out is that even though there are
widespread fears that there be crowd out
of employer-sponsored health insurance
by the expansions and publix and public
insurance about half of the expansion in
insurance coverage in massachusetts
came through public services and the
other half came from expansions in
employer-sponsored health insurance so
there was actually a crowd in to
employer-sponsored health insurance on
net so now on to the first paper which
is joint with my co-author professor
jonathan kolstad of wharton where we
examined the impact on health hospital
and preventive care so the approach of
this paper is very simple it's a simple
difference in different strategy
compared Massachusetts to other states
after the reform relatives before the
reform and we're going to examine what
happened in hospitals to length of stay
admissions from the emergency room
preventive care and costs and the main
source of data that will use for this is
data from hospitals across the entire
United States so first since I have
limited times I'll time I'll jump right
to the findings our first main finding
is that we see a reduction in length of
stay and one reason you might think that
you'd see a reduction in length of stay
is is if you have more insurers in the
market there might be more management of
care and then they're called also be
changes in treatment patterns so we see
that the reduction in length of stay
occurred the most for the people who had
the longest stays and when we talked to
doctors they said that before the reform
they had been reluctant to to discharge
their patients from the hospital if they
thought that those patients couldn't get
adequate follow-up care but after the
reform one reason why we might see a
decreased length of stay is that if
people now have health insurance
coverage they get they can get follow-up
care outside the hospital and so doctors
might might discharge them sooner I also
want to point out that if we think about
traditional moral hazard which says that
as the generosity of insurance increases
then a utilization will increase that is
not consistent with the reductions in
length of stay that we observe that
would have predicted that we would have
seen an increase in length of stay the
second thing that we examine is what
happened to admissions from the
emergency room so we were examining
hospital data so we didn't actually have
the hospital discharges themselves but
we could see the next best thing how
many people were admitted to the
hospital from the emergency room and you
could see that there was a large decline
in the percentage of the population that
was admitted to
hospital from the emergency room overall
people were two percent less likely to
be admitted from the emergency room
which is a five percent decline relative
to the baseline and then also you see
that those declines were much more
pronounced among the lowest income
groups which were the ones that were
more likely to gain health insurance
coverage through the reform and so it
this does seem to show that when people
gain health insurance coverage through
the reform they're less likely to be
admitted to the hospital through the
emergency room and we're recent research
has also confirmed using the data from
the emergency rooms themselves the
Massachusetts saw fewer emergency room
visits than other states over this time
period another thing that we wanted to
examine is what happened to prevention
well it's very hard to examine
prevention because we think that
prevention that occurs through health
insurance might happen over the very
long run but there are some things that
we can examine in the short term so for
example there are some things that
people should never show up in the
hospital for if there's adequate
preventive care so for example example
they shouldn't be coming to the hospital
because they're appendicitis was so
mismanaged that their appendix gets
perforated and they shouldn't be showing
up at the hospital because their adult
asthma is mismanaged the agency for
Healthcare Research and quality put
together 13 of these measures and we
examined what happened to these measures
in Massachusetts relative to other
states after the reform relative to
before the reform and we saw
improvements in three of these measures
without risk adjustment and then when we
did risk adjustment we saw improvements
in more of these measures and also when
we examine survey data we do find that
this is consistent with people reporting
that they had more access to care
outside of the hospital so lastly what
happened to costs costs are really hard
to find in the health care sector
because as some of you know the prices
that are charged in hospitals are are
actually numbers that are always
discounted for insurers and also for
people without insurance and so the
measure of cost that we're going to
examine is the cost that the hospitals
report to Medicare of having to pay to
provide the care that they provide so
this doesn't include the cost of
uncommon sated care this is the
hospital's actual expenditure
so in this slide here I show what
happened to hospital costs over the time
period in Massachusetts and in other
states and you can see that in
Massachusetts costs were growing at a
higher rate than they were in other
states before reform and they continued
growing on that same growth trajectory
after the reform which suggests that
Massachusetts health reform did not bend
the cost curve within hospitals the cost
continues growing at the same rate one
of the big caveats that I want to make
to Annette this analysis is that even
though we do think that hospital costs
are important drivers of overall health
insurance costs this does not take into
account the cost to the government of
about eight hundred million dollars in
the first year of expanding coverage and
it also doesn't take into account the
cost that individuals paid for their
health insurance coverage so we think
about what this overall analysis implies
for national health reform we haven't
done a full cost benefit analysis we see
that on the care side we saw reductions
in length of stay we saw fewer
admissions from the emergency room some
improvements in preventive care and we
also see that hospital costs didn't
increase beyond their trajectory so so
on net we see some benefits but that's
and that's a precursor to satisfying a
cost benefit analysis but it certainly
doesn't take into account the full
picture so then moving on to the second
paper what happened to the labor market
again this is more this is joint work
with John kolstad at Wharton so our
theory is that we're going to develop a
model of health insurance in the labor
market this is going to build on the
summers 1989 model where the essence of
the theory is that if individuals value
the health insurance coverage that they
receive through their employers then
their wages should go down by the amount
of money that they insure spent on that
their that the employer spent on that
coverage for them and the employer
shouldn't have to reduce employment at
all so then we're going to test the
theory by looking what happened in
Massachusetts health reform to wages for
people who took up employer sponsored
health insurance and it's going to be
really important to be able to examine
the same individuals over time as
opposed to just looking at the aggregate
population because the theory just
predicts what will happen to wage
changes
given individuals that switch health
insurance status so this chart shows the
main results of the paper what I've
drawn here is the wage pre-ban for jobs
with employer-sponsored health insurance
minus jobs without employer sponsored
health insurance and this is from a
regression with individual fixed effects
so it's comparing the same individual
when he or she has employer sponsored
health insurance to that same individual
when he or she does not so before the
reform those switches are endogenous and
because because people might have
employer-sponsored health insurer might
switch to a job with employer-sponsored
health insurance when they get a better
job but the goal of our strategy is that
the Massachusetts health reform
exogenously shift people shifted people
into employer sponsored health insurance
and you see this this big decrease in
wages for those people that were
exhausted into employer sponsored health
insurance because of Massachusetts
health reform and the magnitude suggest
that the declines and ranges that those
people saw were roughly equivalent to
the cost that the employer spent on
providing that health insurance and so
when we builded this back up using our
model it suggests that people valued
almost they value the health insurance
that they received it almost a dollar
for the dollar of the employers
expenditure I also want to point out
that there's very little data in this
last point here so you shouldn't think
about an uptick at the end we see wage
declines in those for those individuals
so now what does all of this imply for
national reform well we saw very little
impact on the aggregate labor market
what I've shown you is just the impact
on wages for people who switched
employer sponsored health insurance
status so we moved predict very little
impact on the aggregate labor market but
for people who switch to
employer-sponsored health insurance we
predict declines in wages and those ways
declines are good news for the
efficiency of the policy because they
suggest that employers don't have to
decrease employment when they start
providing employer sponsored health
insurance because employees value the
health insurance benefits that they
received this finding could also explain
why we see crowd in to
employer-sponsored health insurance so
firms might say we don't want to have to
pay for employer-sponsored health
insurance but our research shows that
actually
a the workers are paying for the
employer sponsored health insurance that
they received through the forums through
decreased wages and that could explain
why in Massachusetts we saw an increase
in employer-sponsored health insurance
before the reform and also be after the
reform and also the the tax treatment of
how employers how employees can pay
their premiums is different under
national reform than it was under
Massachusetts reform and we think that
that differential tax treatment could
cause even greater crowding to
employer-sponsored health insurance than
what we saw in Massachusetts which
stands in stark contrast to other
findings that you would have heard in
literature and that you would have heard
during the presidential debate so lastly
I'd like to talk about one other paper
that's also joint with a graduate
student at Yale Martin Hackman and in
this paper we examine what happened to
adverse selection in Massachusetts after
the reform so as many of you know one of
the largest rationales for having an
individual mandate is that by mandating
health insurance coverage we can
overcome the problem of adverse
selection because we no longer we'll
have people selecting into the health
insurance pool and the theory says that
if there is adverse selection because
the healthiest people have already
selected into the pool then the average
cost for insurers will be higher before
the mandate when there is adverse
selection then they are after the
mandate when you've mitigated adverse
selection with the mandate and so what
we're going to do is we're going to
develop that fear a little bit further
and then we're going to test for it
directly by looking at costs to
hospitals it costs to insurers in
hospitals for insured patients in
Massachusetts before the reform relative
to after the reform so we're going to be
able to directly test was there adverse
selection in Massachusetts by using the
variation induced by the mandate will
use some variation across states but
what I'll show you is also variation
within States so counties within
Massachusetts that saw greater increases
in coverage should also see greater
decrease in the cost to insurers for the
insured population if there was adverse
selection which is indeed what we see in
this graph so what I show you along the
horizontal
access is that the increase in coverage
by county and along the vertical cover
access I show the change in cost per
insured person and you do see that
downward slope suggests that there was
adverse selection the magnitude of that
slope suggests that hospital costs went
down for insured people by about one
hundred twenty four dollars per person
per year so to put that in context
that's about three percent of the
national average individual premium this
also appears to be caught to have been
passed on to to have been passed on to
the insured persons through reductions
in premiums so you heard in the debate
that premiums have increased over time
they're increasing everywhere over time
and premiums in the employer sponsored
health insurance market in Massachusetts
did increase over time following the
national trend but premiums in the non
group market actually decreased by
twenty percent which we think could
really have to do with that there was
adverse selection in the non group
insurance market so as we think of what
this applies for the national reform it
does show that the mandate is a powerful
tool to reduce adverse selection and
also Massachusetts was a state that
already had Community Rating regulations
before the reform which means that
individuals in the non group market in
Massachusetts were all charged the same
price regardless of their age or health
status or smoking status and so we've
seen is if you have Community Rating
without a mandate there is adverse
selection and so that's what we would
probably have seen if the Supreme Court
had not upheld the individual mandate so
just to conclude I'll just give you the
major takeaways from the three papers so
back to the first paper the impact on
hospital costs and preventive care we
saw reductions in length of stay fewer
admissions from the emergency room some
evidence of increased prevention no
change in hospital cost growth when we
turn to the labor market we saw that
there was no impact on overall wages or
employment but for those individuals who
took up employer-sponsored health
insurance we saw a wage decreases there
were about the magnitude of what their
employers spent on their health
insurance which suggests that this could
be a very efficient policy in that
workers are bearing the burden of their
increased health insurance and so then
firms don't have to decrease employment
and then lastly we saw that there was
indeed adverse selection in
Massachusetts before the reform and we
would expect similar adverse selection
under national reform if we had
Community Rating without a mandate I'm
happy to answer any other questions
so that was very interesting let's let's
figure out the syllogism that that you
were describing that is to say Obamacare
equals Romneycare Romneycare works there
for Romney what Romney wants to repeal
Obamacare that doesn't seem to work does
it logically but anyway that was very
very interesting um why don't we have a
little bit of discussion up here and
then we'll open up for broader for
broader questions from the audience um
maybe a first logical question to ask a
Alan would be what do you think of the
potential the strategy that Michael
gratz favors of instead of using trying
to reform the income tax of by doing
base broadening and eliminate
eliminating deductions and lowering
rates that may be a brand new
consumption tax combined with
progressivity in the income tax might be
a solution do you think that makes sense
I agree with that I think to relate that
a little bit more precisely to the
problems of say governor Romney's
proposal about base broadening you can't
there isn't as much bass broadening
possible if you especially if you take
these popular tax expenditures off the
table but even if you don't even if you
leave them on the table and take them
away i think one of the country perhaps
controversial points but certainly valid
is that the it's very hard to keep the
distribution of tax payments the same if
you cut rates and so you're sort of
stuck if you're trying to keep a
distributional ii neutral tax system
under the income tax but bring down
income tax rates and so you need to do
something else particularly and if and
particularly to want to raise revenue
and so i agree that some sort of
reformed tax like evaluated text makes a
lot of sense Michael mentioned the
proposal I had that's for a piece of it
which would apply to the corporate and
convert the corporate income tax there
are a lot of proposals out there for
reasons which are puzzling to a student
of tax policy rather than
to a politician value-added taxes are
universally hated by politicians that is
it's it's a tax that it's one of the
things I have a sort of an axiom I keep
in my head which is that the only truly
bad ideas that are supported by Congress
are things that have bipartisan support
and I guess maybe a a corollary of that
is that that the only good ideas or
ideas that nobody in Congress supports
but but the value-added tax is viewed on
both sides with suspicion for different
reasons obviously and but but I I don't
think that should be a reason to keep to
stop putting it forward because it does
make a lot of logical sense and unlike
proposals simply to have the value-added
tax is the only source of revenue a
proposal like Michaels does allow one to
maintain progress civet E and some
flexibility and the tax burdens that are
imposed on higher income people which
relates not only two real concerns about
progressivity but also perhaps more
superficial concerns about appearances
of taxes sometimes even if you aren't
raising a lot of revenue from some
provisions their existence makes
political sense let's just let me try to
spell some of that out and ask a
question so the audience completely gets
that argument so Democrats don't like
the value-added tax because in the
absence of the kind of combination with
a more progressive income tax by itself
value-added taxes regressive or at least
not not progressive it's a flat tax on
consumption so what a Republicans hate
it Republicans hate it because they
think that efficiency and taxation is
the enemy of small government of small
of small government so if your objective
is small government you want the
government to be constrained to raise
taxes in the least productive ways so
that it can raise very little I think
that's probably maybe oversimplification
but I think that's basically the
argument so so Larry Summers
once quipped that the Democrats don't
like the value-added tax because they
think it's regressive and the
Republicans don't like it because they
think it's a money machine and when the
Republicans learn that it's regressive
and the Democrats learned that it's a
money machine they'll both support it
and and and I have to say what what I've
tried to do in my proposal is to make
sure that it's not regressive which
which I think I've succeeded in and to
use it to buy down the income tax and to
buy down the income tax by removing
people from the tax with through this
hundred-thousand-dollar exemption and
thereby use up enough money that it's
not a money machine so that the proposal
was designed so that it would not be
regressive and it would not be a money
machine well you could you could draw
the line though on the income tax exempt
on the exemption for many cats anywhere
you want and make it a revenue
augmenting or revenue yeah well you can
also you can also raise revenues by
raising that 15 and a half percent
fifteen percent rate you can raise the
top rate on income taxes there's a lot
of money here you can raise seventy
billion dollars a year with a one
percent increase in the value added tax
so there's plenty more money to be had
and when I say plenty I mean enough to
help finance debt reduction over the
projections but there's not there's not
the ability to put in a five percent
value added tax to finance debt
reduction leave the income tax with all
of its problems in place and then have
the value added tax grow which is the
Republicans fear I just want to say two
things about the politics of it one is
Ben Cardin who is a Democratic senator
from Maryland said to be in a Finance
Committee hearing you know the Senate
would vote a hundred 20 not to cut
Social Security benefits not to cut
Medicare benefits not to cut Medicaid
benefits and not to have a value-added
tax but we all know we've got to do all
of that
and and so at some point we've got to do
it and I would say the fact that the Pew
Charitable Trust had the Tax Policy
Center estimate this the parameters of
this plan suggests that it is actually
and I know it for a fact it's actually
being talked about quietly in political
circles because tax policy center
doesn't estimate private people's plans
they estimate presidential candidates
plans and the like and important
congressional plans but they rarely
estimate a private plan so I I
understand the political barriers to a
value-added tax but but I think it's
also inevitable in some in some
fundamental way um bringing over to the
coming over the healthcare side of the
story and how it play your findings were
very interesting in terms of showing the
way in which from the perspective of the
individual patient the individual
citizen Romneycare you know reduce the
cost of caring for that person and
reduced adverse selection had many
desirable properties what but act but of
course as you mentioned the the
aggregate cost to society wasn't small
because the there you're bringing a lot
of people in what what do you what do
you think that mean to what extent would
the repeal of Obamacare actually make a
dent in the federal budget deficit
problem in other words is what what's
the what's the revenue application of
the Obamacare Gordon Jackson okay so so
one thing one thing that I didn't get
into very much was the cost reductions
that are also part of the national
health reform that weren't in the
Massachusetts health reform so the big
numbers to have in your head are that
the Massachusetts health reform cost
about 800 million for one year the
national health reform will cost about
940 billion over ten years so then if
you think about what does that cost per
state let's let's say let's not even do
it by population and then say the state
Massachusetts was only one fiftieth what
would that cost per state that amounts
to about 1.8 billion each year for
States and you thank gee that's a lot
more than in Massachusetts where that
was 800mm
but that actually makes sense because
other states have lower levels of
coverage than Massachusetts and so the
subsidies are going to go to more people
and they're going to extend higher so
the costs are going to be much higher
under the national health reform than
they were under the Massachusetts health
reform but actually there are also some
ways that there are revenue increases
and spending cuts so under the national
health reform there's there the cuts to
Medicare Advantage plans and then there
are also cuts to hospital reimbursement
that's what you heard in the debate was
the 716 billion per year that Obama and
Romney were both talking about and then
addition to that there were revenue
increases so there's a new Cadillac tax
on generous health insurance plans
there's a new payroll tax that's not
also not only going to be on payroll but
is going to be on a broader base for
families that have incomes above
$250,000 so that's going to raise some
revenues and then there are also big new
taxes on insurers medical device
companies and pharmaceutical companies
and so all told when you put together
those revenue increases and those in
those spending cuts even though the cost
of meant of the national health reform
is seems much larger than it was for
Massachusetts health reform the
Congressional Budget Office as to
estimates that over ten years there'll
be a deficit reduction of 143 billion
through because of the because of the
national health reform so if you if you
actually repealed the national health
reform the congressional budget estimate
the congressional budget office
estimates that we would actually be have
a greater deficit than we would with it
the 143 is a net or you mentioned does
94 net number yeah so yeah so so the CBO
says that there's a net cost savings
from the national health reform well
okay very good why don't we see what
people in the audience would like to ask
of our panelists um that we have
microphones on either see the aisle and
so the best system is to since it's hard
to hear from the audience without a mic
if you come up you know line up between
behind the two microphones and I'll just
call
leon on the two locations yes I'm a
business student I have a question for
professor Amanda it's all right i can't
read you'll be in your research you find
that the cost to employers who provide
employer-sponsored health insurance is
almost offset dollar for dollar by
declining wages which is really
interesting and on the surface it
appears that like workers would be
indifferent like they could either keep
their wages or have this health care so
I'm curious how you explain why workers
are voluntarily making this move and
what is it that attracts them to having
the employer sponsored health care as
opposed to having just having their
wages which is the same thank you for
that question I think you raised a very
interesting point because what I was
talking about was distortion to the
labor market and so this is a very
efficient policy when you think about
distortions in the labor market because
firms don't have to cut the cut
employment because workers are actually
paying for the benefits but then you
when you think about the distortions to
the consumption bundles of employees
they're actually could be a large
distortion they're so so by definition
if employees didn't have
employer-sponsored health insurance
before the reform they were making a
choice a revealed preference not to have
employer-sponsored health insurance now
when the penalty comes into into place
if they have to have employer-sponsored
health insurance or pay a penalty they
value employer-sponsored health
insurance more but that this that
penalty actually distorts the money that
they could be spending on other things
and so we do want to think take that
into account but the analysis is the
analysis of the labor market alone
doesn't take that into account don't I
have a question for professor our back
and maybe also professor Kowalski so
Alan you showed a really skip scary a
diagram you're your worst case I'm there
maybe there's one thing about being old
you know I won't be there in 20 160 with
a 700 / you know seven hundred percent G
debt-to-gdp what I wondered about is
underlying generally those calculations
how much of the increase is
is demographics and how much of it is
projections about increases in spending
per per eligible person relative to GDP
and then the final thing which connects
to that is Paul Ryan and I'm not quite
sure exactly what is in the you know
Romney's position but a number of people
proposed essentially relating or capping
Medicare expenditures on a per capita
basis to gdp with with some growth
built-in so I wonder if you might
comment on both demographics versus
projections about healthcare costs and
the potential for these others that kind
of a reform thank you Joe the share of
the long-run imbalances that come from
demographics plus healthcare growth
together is pretty much the whole thing
and of that the a growing share comes
from X so-called xxs health cost growth
that is health expenditures real health
expenditures per capita controlling for
changes in the population it so if you
look out 10 or 20 or 30 years a big
chunk of it is demographics but then
over time the demographics sort of
settled down and things just keep
getting worse because of because of
health costs growth I wanted to make a
point about that many people look at
those shares and they say we don't have
a budget problem we have a health care
problem that is we shouldn't be looking
to cut various things in the budget or
raise taxes to deal with long run
imbalances because it's all in health
care that's as far as I can see it's a
non sequitur because the fact that
health care cost is growing doesn't mean
the health care costs health care
spending should be cut so that it
doesn't grow because their reasons not
just demographics which obviously is
something you can't really do anything
about but even the so-called excess
health cost growth could simply
represent a natural evolution
of spending patterns as incomes grow and
it could well be that as medical
technology changes people want to spend
a larger share of their income this
could be happening in the private sector
without any government in the
intervention you can have more spending
on healthcare as a share of income over
over time and a solution to that isn't
to keep it from happening it could be
too much of it is happening because of
the way our healthcare market is
structured but simply to observe that
that just in terms of the arithmetic the
growing share you know and a majority
and in the long run of the excess of
spending over revenues is associated
with growth in health care doesn't
really tell you anything about what
fraction of the changes from the current
policy trajectory should occur within
healthcare rather than rather than
elsewhere I am not sure if there was
anything else I should have addressed
but Amanda might have more to say on
that I guess I'll jump in and answer the
second half of Professor LNG's question
thinking about capping expenditures
beyond a certain growth rate and I guess
I'll just point out that there is
something called the Independent Payment
Advisory Board that was enacted as that
will come into place as part of the
Affordable Care Act which will be able
to make reservations on what should be
cut if the health expanded national
health expenditures are higher than a
target I think its GDP plus one percent
and then Congress will have to do an
up-or-down vote vote I think what's
interesting there is even though the
candidates have both candidates have
proposals about limiting medical care
expenditures beyond if the beyond growth
GDP targets the ipad the Independent
Payment Advisory Board has been very
unpopular that's what's been been called
the death panel and the popular debates
can I just make one one comment about
this one thing about the health story is
there's a lot of shell game stuff going
on that is we're going to move it off
the federal budget into private budgets
or we're going to move it
the federal budget on to state budgets
or a combination of state budgets and
private budgets and it doesn't change
the overall expenditures to do that and
it seems that that's where the proposals
many of them not the health board but
many of them are just designed to make
budget accounting better the other thing
to say which Alan didn't include in his
chart but if you'd look at changes in
the CBO's long-term estimates over time
the biggest change in the last few years
is the growth in interest on the federal
debt which is compounding in in some
sense and if you look at the at the CBS
estimates for the total debt owed to the
public under what they you know the sort
of their middle estimate in the
optimistic pessimistic lines that Alan
showed so in 2022 just to take ten years
from now something you might care about
more than 60 the the debt is estimated
to be at about 20 trillion dollars and
we've enjoyed extremely favorable
interest rates which we may not enjoy
forever and so if you think interest
rates on the federal debt are then five
percent that's a trillion dollars a year
of interest payments on the federal debt
half of which at least is going to
foreigners and so this is a very big
problem and and that's a new problem
that is the demographic problem and the
health care costs problem is one that
people have been talking about for some
time not doing much about the talking
about but but the interest on the
federal debt really makes this much a
much bigger problem and a much more
urgent problem for for Congress to get
under control any response to that
element no I agree the growing interest
on the federal debt is simply a
manifestation of of procrastination
we've known about the problems for a
long time where they're getting were
they've gotten worse
what sooner because of the recession and
the large deficits that occurred then
but the bulk of the problem is still
what we face in the long run let me
probe a little bit more on this question
of how do we account for the rising
share of health care costs in GDP
because I think you're kind of
suggesting and there's some evidence to
support you being right that that that
this is just a matter of changing
consumer preference over time as we get
wealthier we spend more on health care
it's a it's a it's a it's got an income
elasticity greater than one the like
many like many goods and you could say
so there's nothing there should be no no
pejorative view about rising health care
costs rising two percent of GDP sort of
the flip side on the supply side of set
of saying that well it's okay that
manufacturing is now nine percent of GDP
when it used to be thirty-five percent
of GDP it's a natural evolution on the
other hand um you know the question is
are there some are there any distortions
that are that are quite and by the way
private sector expenditure on health
care is going up faster than gdp it's
not just all medicare and medicaid
medicaid but you know they think the
question is are there distortions in the
health care market that may lead to this
phenomenon and that and that I mean are
there market failures I mean one that's
pointed to a lot and when it's quite a
partisan divisive issue is the quiz sort
of the torque is that is the tort system
which which creates strong incentives to
overprescribe the over intervene and and
and expend money on end-of-life care
when perhaps from us from a medical or
ethical or even family preference point
of view that might not be warranted
that's one there might be others what do
you what do you what do you all think
about that or there are there are there
way other other issues in health care
that that ought to be grappled with in
order to control its costs rather than
just capping expenditures yeah so as we
think about the intersection between
health policy and tax policy we saw that
the largest tax expenditure is actually
the exclusion for employer-sponsored
health insurance and that's actually not
a very popular provision around among
most health economist because we do
think that that might encourage higher
spending on health insurance and on
medical care and might also contribute
to the growth rate in medical
expenditures so among health economist
that's not a very popular policy what's
interesting is that because the
incidence of that policy is very
widespread that's the only that that's
the biggest reason why we're peeling
that that tax expenditure that that
loophole for the tax exclusion for
employer-sponsored health insurance
isn't popular but but I think yes that
could be causing a very large distortion
that might even affect the growth rate
and not just the level of medical
expenditure I just just add that there's
a an argument that is made in favor of
that provision or at least its existence
is that certainly without something like
Obamacare if we went back to the market
we had the situation we had before where
a lot of people were there was a
tendency for people to be uninsured that
giving the exclusion for
employer-provided health insurance was a
way of encouraging employers and
employees together to to have insurance
to employ employment it's obvious to
economists would think about that that
is that you might want to give a sort of
a subsidy to having insurance but you
don't necessarily want to subsidize ever
larger subsidy purchases of health
insurance and first dollar coverage and
interestingly a proposal that was made
both by President Bush and a modified
version by Senator McCain when he was
running for president would have been to
give a lump basically a lump sum tax
expenditure for having coverage but
nothing on the margin and I've actually
thought that was a very productive idea
and I guess adherent get consistent with
my original axiom that good ideas are
you know have our ideas that nobody
supports that this is I think one of
them
Thanks it made clearly linking health
insurance to employment creates lots of
distortion small employers don't provide
it large employers do I mean you go
through the list I mean I just think
that Alan's point that which is an
interesting point is that if you just
were to describe an industry with major
technological advance growth of income
because every dollar of cost is
somebody's income and so forth you could
you could describe a much more benign
economic picture of what's going on in
the health care sector than the one we
usually hear so its a mix but they're
clearly distortions because of what
we're what we're doing and you mentioned
medical malpractice and and clearly
there are problems in the in the tort
system that should be fixed i think i
think everybody it's interesting i think
the democrats maybe they won't vote for
it because of the political concerns but
but they're moved they now I think
there's now widespread agreement on that
point yes this is a question that goes
to the entire panel and hasn't been
discussed as much tonight but I know in
times when the the debt-to-gdp ratio
gets very high for a lot of countries
inflating the currency slightly to use
that debt load is definitely an option
is that something that could happen for
America later on would that be a good
thing or a positive solution I think
there's a general consensus among
economists that the evolution of
independent central bank's has been has
contributed to this being less of a
problem than it used to be and the Fed
is independent usually a quite annoying
way to politicians but I think you need
some sort of monetary accommodation for
a deficit policy to be inflationary and
well the Fed may be under some pressure
to do that I think they're pretty
committed and it established a
reputation for for being committed
committed to two relative price
stability not not zero inflation but low
rates of inflation so that I don't see
that as a as a likely channel for
dealing with the debt one thing I would
say by the way
is that people often think of inflation
as that's sort of a necessary evil for
dealing with the debt that is we may not
want it but if we've got this debt we
don't know how else to deal with it and
we have political gridlock maybe this
will happen and we'll just live with it
most of our fiscal imbalances would not
be lessened by an inflation because
they're essentially index to the price
level are real problems are growing
Medicare costs our growing social
security benefits are either implicitly
or explicitly indexed for inflation that
is they get they go up if the price of
crisis go up so if we were to have a
very high rate surprise rate of
inflation for a long period of time we
would maybe erode the real value of the
national debt but that would actually
lessen our long-run fiscal imbalances by
a very small percentage okay thank you
yeah hello I have one quick question one
more broad question the quick one for
professor Kowalski um regarding your
analysis of adverse selection I think it
was interesting methodologically and I'm
wondering what relationship that has
with the first paper you presented which
is that other effects not related to
adverse selection reduce the cost of
hospital care per person so how much of
that explains the bad reflection result
and then secondly the broader question
relating to a slide that presser
Auerbach showed I was alarmed at the
scale on the future GD the future debt
to GDP growth showed it going up to
something like seven hundred percent in
2060 to obviously there's the axiom what
what can't go on forever won't and I
think we'd agree that that can't go on
forever so what's the political
threshold if you will and what are the
steps that that have to happen at some
point and when do we hit that point
thank you okay so so I'll rephrase the
first question and when we think about
reconciling the findings in the first
paper and the findings in the third
paper as we see declines in length of
stay in the first paper and we would
think that if there was adverse
selection into
health insurance or into the hospital
before the reform then we might
naturally see declines in length of stay
as you get more people covered because
the people who will be going into the
hospitals are actually going to be the
healthier people than they were so
actually what we find is when we risk
adjust when we control for the health
status of the people coming into the
hospitals using the most advanced
methods that we have using not only
demographic characteristics but but
other ailments that they have we see
that the length of stay findings persist
so the effects in the hospital in terms
of length of stay and admissions from
the emergency room don't appear to be
driven by healthier people showing up at
the hospitals but the cost picture could
actually reflect healthier people
showing up at the hospitals in a more
complex question oh yeah answer to the
broader question about when way I guess
when does the music stop is really the
question about the debt-to-gdp ratio and
the for the United States it would stop
probably much later than for Greece or
Spain or Italy and that in a sense is
it's bad news it's bad news because it
means that the fiscal adjustments which
are inevitable will be delayed and
because there'd be delayed they will
probably have to be more draconian in
terms of being concentrated on a smaller
group of generations of cohorts of
individuals and I don't think there's so
that people talk about the u.s. hitting
having a financial crisis where it can't
borrow it's we don't seem to be close to
that right now to put it mildly and and
there's also been some some suggestion
that an impetus would come from the
dollar losing its status as a reserve
currency I think the United Kingdom
Japan and the euro area are doing
everything they can to keep that from
happening so there's nothing there's no
nothing driving i think a solution and i
think it's so i think it could very well
be far in the future and and then when
it happens it'll probably happen to have
to happen relatively quickly because it
the delay will allow the debt-to-gdp
ratio to get very high and then at some
point it really
we'll have to be dealt with if only
because the interest payments at that
point Michael's point will be occupying
such a large share of government
expenditures it'll be obvious to
everybody that that can't continue and
at that point we'll probably have a
poorly conceived and rapidly designed
cut in various programs could take the
form of very sharp means-testing because
if they'd government decides well since
we didn't act 20 years ago and we have
to cut Medicare benefits today we can't
go to 80 year olds of all incomes and
say we're cutting your benefits in half
but we can do it to individuals with
incomes in the top ten percent of the
population for example and so we my
guess is we're going to see a lot of
that kind of cut that is cuts that are
delayed and cuts that are opportunistic
in terms of who can who can pay for them
yes yeah it's working this question is
for the entire panel I'm just following
up on the remarks on compound interest
and this might be too broad of a
question for this forum but where do you
think we got off allowing compound
interest I mean for for about four
thousand years before 1694 it was
completely banned religiously as well as
morally and I mean just just just the
idea of compound interest is terrifying
I mean it's it's I'm doing research on
it currently in it it has seemed to
started Wars looting immorality in
general and where do you think we got
off allowing that to come about okay are
you looking at me
I think speaking for the economics
profession that we generally think that
allowing financial markets to operate is
a good thing now we certainly have some
recent examples where that it did things
didn't always work out that great people
make bad decisions both in the private
sector and the public sector they borrow
too much they they whether it's
defaulting on the house or a city
defaulting because it borrowed too much
or state getting into financial trouble
these things happen but I think
prescribing what is generally beneficial
market activity because of the problems
associated with individual transactions
i think it's an extremely gross and
undesirable mechanism for dealing with
it i think that's why for the private
sector we've been we've have we have
regulation of financial activity and
we've certainly been thinking a lot more
about that in the last few years we
struggle more in terms of how we
constrain governments in part because
it's hard to design rules that work very
effectively nevertheless I think still
think that's the better objective and
then then simply ruling out a important
sector of transactions so we are earlier
talking about a question was suggesting
you know when can this go on forever and
now we have the expert in the field who
once wrote a paper called we can't
disagree forever is that true professor
gene accomplice or would you like to ask
a question I was hoping to ask a
question but a long goes very light um
so for some simple minded people this
has been a very arid aight discussion by
the way I've learned a lot but for some
you mean for just a country economist
justify your I've done that myself the
Summoner you can get away with it but
you can't get away with it he's Greek I
know
it was a simple Greek economy front for
a number of people planning to vote next
month I've heard people boil it down
basically to this that romney wants to
cut taxes that just doesn't add up given
our deficits and the looming deficits in
the future we have no choice but to
raise taxes and he wants to cut them he
must be crazy so I'm therefore we should
vote for Obama that simple-minded
argument I think actually persuades a
lot of people so I wonder if you could
discuss it is it a legitimate argument
do you think Romney actually is saying
one thing is going to do basically the
same thing Obama would or is this a
reason why it's untenable to see what
are we wrong knee is probably can we
modify the question to take out the last
implication that is to say just ask the
question is it crazy to think you can
get away with cutting taxes fine the
throng neutral way of asking question
but but we're we're talking about the
election and who we're gonna vote for no
you're thinking about that we're talking
about the economics well I think the
title of the panel is about the election
so i want to hear obama said romney's
proposing to cut five trillion dollars
worth of taxes is he really proposing
that if he were proposing that is that
crazy what what can you make of this
debate where they seem not to be able to
converse with each other about the
substance of what they're doing so so
what he said let me just describe what
he said most recently so so he said over
and over during the campaign that he
wants to cut tax rates individual income
tax rates he's got a corporate proposal
by twenty percent over ten year period
that's four point eight trillion dollars
that's the rounding to five trillion
dollars so that costs five trillion
dollars he has also said to other things
one is that he's going to pay for that
through base broadening and i guess he
said three three things in the debate he
said and he wasn't going to add and
dime to the deficit through tax
reduction and he said he wasn't going to
lower taxes on higher income people the
Tax Policy centers analysis which i
think is a reasonable analysis although
there has been some question as to
whether it's taken into account the
economic growth that will be unleashed
through this tax rate reduction which I
have to say I think is is hard to see in
the sense that you know we're now 35% we
didn't see a lot of growth when we got
went from 39 2.62 35 you know you know I
I believe when we went from 91 to 72 to
28 which we did in the Reagan years that
actually might have made a big
difference in terms of people's behavior
and economic growth it's hard with these
small things to know how big the growth
dividend is but but in any event he said
he's not going to reduce taxes on
high-income people he's not going to add
a dollar to the deficit through tax
reduction and he's going to cut rates
twenty percent also not raise taxes on
middle-income and not raise taxes on
middle-income people which which which
is very difficult because if you look at
the distribution of that seventy percent
of the tax expenditures that i described
health insurance employer pensions
itemized deductions for charitable
interest taxes and the light and the
Earned Income Tax Credit which is at the
bottom a lot of that money is in the
middle now there are things you can do
that will pick up some money but I think
it's very hard to pick up the five
trillion and the five trillion is
against a baseline that assumes that the
current tax rates and so forth don't
change so that the baseline is current
policy not the current law which would
repeal the bush tax cuts if we go off
allons a cliff and so I think it doesn't
add up in some sense and something's got
to give that is I think
as a former president put arithmetic I
think that's arithmetic what gives is
uncertain one of the things that might
give for example is the determination to
to keep none of the base broad nurs on
capital income and so you hear people
close to the Romney campaign saying well
if we need to repeal the tax advantages
that life insurance companies for
example now enjoy we could do that there
seems to be a desire to repeal the tax
benefits for tax-exempt bonds which
would hurt state and local governments
by increasing their financing and her a
Yale University which has been able to
finance Yale and other large
universities been able to finance
through tax-exempt bond issues and so
forth so that if you start you know
going in capital gains you know what do
we do about capital gains what do we do
about some of those things you began to
you begin to help yourself but it's a
very large lift to get anywhere near the
five trillion dollars and so one example
is the day before the debate well Mike
but you said there were 1.1 trillion in
tax expenditures annually and and we're
talking about hitting half a trillion
you can't so you could theoretically
we're getting rid of half the tax
expenditures could close the gap but
that's it yes yeah but you know when you
look at them it politically hardened
it's it's very hard to get anywhere near
a half a trillion dollars from them I
mean I you know I didn't count
tax-exempt bond interest and you know
that's just not going to happen it's
going to be taxable and so forth so I
you know I think it's going to be very
hard and it's very hard to reduce the
rates i think the rate cut will be
smaller if Romney is elected than he is
then he said during the campaign if he
moves in that direction one of the
things that's very interesting is he
said the day before the debate well one
idea he didn't say it was he's going to
propose it is to cap itemized deductions
that
seventeen thousand dollars well the
standard deduction is now twelve
thousand so if you're going to cap at
17,000 you might as well just repeal the
itemized deductions between the time he
said that and the debate he then moved
that number to 25,000 or fifty thousand
dollars if you look at 25,000 you're in
the 90th percentile that is an average
itemized deduction so it distributes
much more to the top ten percent but the
90th percentile for everybody is a
hundred and forty-seven thousand dollars
and for the elderly which turn out to
have an average at this level the 90th
percentile is eighty nine thousand
dollars of income so that you're talking
about groups that are important
constituencies and I think once that's
discovered even twenty five thousand is
the wrong way to go and capping of
course is the wrong way to go because it
it it just you know if you're in a high
income tax state the cap that's left
after you pay your state taxes if you're
in Connecticut New York or California is
tiny so you won't have any incentive
hardly at all for charitable deductions
there are there better ways to do this
if you're worried about the effect on
housing prices of cutting the home
mortgage interest deduction or if you're
worried about the effect as I would be
charitable deductions of limiting
itemized deductions you can do floors
instead of ceilings and so forth but
even so I think it's hard to get the
half a trillion dollars a year out of
tax expenditures I just don't see it
Johnny if you two getting back to your
the motivation for your question if
you're a voter trying to think about
which which side is giving you a more
plausible story the only story that
makes any sense I think for how things
are going to have to play on the long
run is it government spending as a share
of GDP it's going to have to raise above
its historical percentage and taxes is a
share of GDP you're going to have to go
along with it and
and you've got I would say two visions
be opposing each other right now neither
of which was consistent with that story
and president I mean Governor Romney
with all the problems these proposals
have on the tax side he has at least
suggested what he would do with
entitlements and I think perhaps
somewhat surprising to me and that these
are likely to be pretty unpopular with
voters particularly in places like
Florida and on the other hand president
Obama has certainly shown a willingness
to increase taxes a moderate amount and
has been rather silent on what would
happen to the spending program so you
would really like to see from any real
in terms of realistic view of the world
something on both sides and you're being
given a choice of incomplete programs on
both on both sides I would say it's a
much more balanced way of putting it
that and I think it's I would totally
agree with that you we cannot get the
story straightened out without
curtailing entitlements to some degree
and without raising taxes to some degree
I mean it's just no other way to close
the gap and that's why I really want to
take on the Auerbach theorem that all
bipartisan legislation is bad because I
i think frankly bipartisan legislation
is much more stable and I mean if you if
we really did get let's say a strong
majority on one side of the other
through this election and and and this
problem were tackled the way Obamacare
was with a completely one-sided vote I
mean one party supporting at the other
party opposing it you have your what you
run this instability that we have right
now which is the next the next election
they run on repealing and you know the
the last legislation the durable
features of us domestic policy not to
mention foreign policy have tended to be
things on which at least there's a
substantial you know vote from from many
members of the minority party to support
the majority legislation and I don't see
a solution to this problem without that
you know I I spent
a lot of time I was told afterwards it
was eleven days but it seemed like about
three months at andrews air force base
in the negotiations of the 90 budget act
where george herbert walker bush knew
that he was going to have to raise taxes
and violate his pledge and was
negotiating with a Democratic House of
the Democratic Senate it is it is the
case that it cost him his reelection and
then I way thanks for the economy and
well it it got the budget on the right
track it was it was then clinton push
that along a little further right but
you know that's what God is to the
surplus as we had in 2001 and I think he
gets a lot of credit among among
economist for doing that so I think
you've got to have a bipartisan solution
I mean my own preference is that you
almost always have to have a divided
government I mean I you know the
question is you know do you want one
party in charge me you want divided
government and I Mike what I took away
from that was it in order to get a
bipartisan solution you need divided
government in one form or another and
and I think that that holds but i'm with
you i think it has to be bipartisan and
i think it has to be it has to be
negotiated it also is the case that for
many of these proposals we're talking
about the third rail of republican
politics on the tax side and medicare
and social security on the Democratic
side it's got to come out of somewhere
in which nobody made the proposal and it
just you know people walk out with a
sheet of paper saying well this was the
agreement and then later they can yell
at each other about one thing or another
and so I think it's got to be that kind
of process and so when people talk about
the grand bargain I think it's got to be
on both sides and I think I think I
think it will happen i'm not as
pessimistic as alan is about how long
it's going to take to happen either but
but he's property great probably we're
kind of at our closing time somebody
asks you each panelist over one for a
one word answer to the following
question i'm selling a security that
pays one dollar in the event that we do
not
go over the fiscal cliff ok so we're
you're going to hit you're going to pay
it you get paid a dollar if if if we
solve the problem before december 31st
or at least avert a disaster what do you
pay for that security I think it's a
certainty I think the adult you pay yeah
yeah and I'll say why I think and this
gets back to this gets back to the
bipartisanship and whether that's good
or bad I think it's going to turn out to
be very easy to extend everything by six
months and I and so if you really mean
December first December first thirty
first fiscal cliff I think no problemo
and you Amanda what do you think I i
think professor era box argument is
compelling that's probably what i heard
in the halls around the bridge so use it
for less than ago happen I i wouldn't
pay as our especially if Romney is
elected I think if Romney is elected
we're going to go the lame duck session
is not going to pass anything and
Obama's not going to sign anything and
we're going to go over the cliff but
then we'll climb right back up off the
cliff with a six month extension or a
year extension or two-year extension if
Romney is elected you know in january or
februari or march so you know i think
we're going to go off the cliff but i
think we're going to stay off the cliff
and see see all that it's like to
clarify this is that we have to we have
to clarify the nature of this contract
because what would probably happen in
that case is the new Congress would meet
in january with president Romney and
they would retroactively Lee yes go back
retro actively pull Wiley coyote up off
the act okay so we we have a we have a
short-term solution anyway thanks so
much thank the panelists for coming and
entertain yourself